What I want to do today is finish
the second installment of phase
diagrams. Last day,
we looked at unary phase diagrams.
That is to say, single component.
That meant all we had to do was
worry about pressure versus
temperature because everything is of
simple composition.
And I have up here on the display a
phase diagram of water which we
looked at last day.
And I have redrawn it here for
convenience. And I just wanted to
draw your attention to several
things. We are looking at how the
stability of the different phases of
water varies with pressure and
temperature. I have drawn the solid
region over here,
single phase, liquid region up here
single phase, and vapor region over
here single phase.
And, at some point,
we transit from solid to liquid.
And it does not happen at a single
point, it happens over a range of
temperatures and pressures along
this line which is called the
coexistence curve.
Whenever you have two phases in
equilibrium, they define a
coexistence curve.
And so here is the solid-liquid
coexistence curve,
liquid-vapor and solid-vapor.
We saw that happens at R life,
which is the one atmosphere isobar.
This equilibrium solid-liquid, that
is ice-water at zero degrees C.
And the normal boiling point,
that is to say, one atmosphere
applied pressure which is nominally
sea level is 100 degrees C.
And we saw how boiling point varies
with applied pressure.
And that is defined along this
coexistence curve.
The other thing to note is that
when the three coexistence curves
intersect, we have this unique set
of circumstances called the triple
point where all three
phases coexist.
And they coexist at only one point.
That is to say, one
temperature-pressure combination,
which is very nearly identical to
the solidification temperature.
This is not to scale. This is
slightly higher than zero degrees C.
It is about 1/100th of a degree
above zero at a reduced pressure of
4.58 millimeters of mercury.
And at this point here, the triple
point, you, in fact,
have ice cubes floating in boiling
water.
And there is the triple point.
And then the last thing was I
talked about supercritical fluids at
the end of last lecture.
Just for completeness, in the case
of water, water turns into a
supercritical fluid at the elevated
temperature of 374 degrees Celsius,
218 atmospheres. Above this
pressure-temperature pair,
we have something that is simply
fluid. It is neither
a liquid nor a vapor.
You could argue that it is a highly
condensed vapor or highly rarefied
liquid, but it has the properties of
a supercritical fluid.
What I want to do today is to now
look at multi-component systems.
And we want to start with two
component systems.
We are not going to be talking about
pure materials.
C will equal two,
so that means now we have to think
about temperature,
pressure and composition,
because composition is a variable
between the two components.
And that gets to be messy because
we already had a
pressure-temperature diagram for
let's say component A.
This is component A. And,
over here, I have the pressure
temperature variation
of component B.
And here I have drawn the solid
liquid coexistence curve as it
normally is found in most materials,
which is to say positive because
solids are generally denser than the
liquids. Water is one of the
exceptions. Now the question is how
do various properties change with
composition? If I ask what is going
on in between here so I
can join these two --
I am going to need a
three-dimensional plot; pressure,
temperature, composition. I have an
infinity of unary phase diagrams all
across here from pure A all the way
over to pure B with all of the
different composition ratios in
between. For example,
here is the melting point of A and
here is the melting point of B.
I might ask how does the melting
point vary with composition.
Is that a case of just connect the
dots? If I know the melting points
of the two end members,
say copper and nickel.
And I want to know what the melting
point of a 50/50 copper-nickel alloy.
Is it just the halfway temperature
between the two,
or does the temperature go through a
local maximum,
or does it go through a local
minimum or does the temperature go
nuts? I mean,
the question is how does temperature
of some critical feature vary with
composition? We need to look at
three-dimensional stability maps.
And this is a pain in the neck
because it is 3D and it is messy.
But, fortunately,
this is 3.091. And 3.
91 is concerned about solid-state
chemistry. In 3.
91, we care more about liquid-solid
equilibrium instead of liquid-vapor
equilibrium because we do not
process too many materials in the
vapor state, we don't use too many
materials as vapors.
This is the equilibrium that is most
important. We know that equilibria
depend upon temperature,
pressure and composition.
And it turns out that when it comes
to the liquid-solid equilibrium,
liquid-solid equilibrium is strongly
dependent, there is a strong
dependence between the temperature
of transformation and composition.
Whereas, the relationship between
the temperature of the
transformation and pressure is
weakly dependent.
There is a weak dependence between
pressure and the temperature of the
transformation.
And we saw that last day.
These are not to scale. In other
words, these lines are nearly
vertical for solid liquid.
You would have to apply geological
pressures to alter the melting point
of water substantially.
Whereas, we saw it doesn't take
anything more than just a rise in
elevation of several thousand feet
to move the boiling point along.
That means I can throw away the
pressure dependence and just focus
on the two-dimensional relationship
between the temperature of a
transformation and the composition.
So that is what we are going to do.
We are going to look at three
different types of binary systems.
And, in each case, we are going to
assume that the pressure is one
atmosphere. And we know that the
dependence of the transformation
temperatures that we write is going
to be negligible in terms of the
impact that pressure might have on
them. We are going to look at three
different types of systems,
and they are all dependent upon the
extent of solubility.
Oh, what is the word?
I have given them the very "catchy"
distinctions of type one,
type two and type three. Let's look
at the type one type of binary
system. And type one binary system
has complete solubility.
By this I mean complete solubility
of the two components.
Complete solubility in solid and
liquid states.
That is to say,
if I mix A and B,
they will mix in all proportions as
solids and will mix in all
proportions as liquids.
And the second thing is we are
looking at change of state.
This diagram applies to a change of
state. And since we are talking
about solid-liquid that is the only
one we need to document.
Let's think about what the relevant
chemistry here is.
I mean, I have been telling you that
phase diagrams are stability maps
and you can just look at them and
consult them. But there are always
some basic chemistry embedded in
these diagrams.
For example, if it were a metal
system and I were to tell you that
these two metals,
A and B, mix in all proportions as
solids and liquids,
what would have to be the
characteristics of those two metals?
They would have to be either very
nearly similar or maximally
different. They would have to be
very nearly similar.
And, in fact, it is sort of a
takeoff on like dissolves like.
Complete solubility in a liquid
state with respect to metals,
when it comes to metals there is a
set of rules called the Hume-Rothery
Rules. Hume-Rothery was a British
metallurgist, and he annunciated a
set of rules for identifying
candidate systems that will have
this type of phase diagram.
And they are very simple.
Anybody in 3.091 would have come up
with these rules if you had thought
about it before Hume-Rothery.
But he beat you to it so you cannot
get the glory anymore.
But let's think about it.
What would have to be the situation?
If the two metals,
A and B, are going to mix in all
proportions then they must be very
similar. They must have similar
crystal structures.
That way you get simple
substitutional solid solutions.
And, furthermore,
if they are going to substitute
solid for solid,
they should have similar atomic
dimensions. It does no good to have
two FCC metals mixing where one has
an atomic radius that is so large it
has to force fit into the lattice of
the other. Similar atomic volumes.
And, lastly, bring in some
chemistry. We want them to mix and
not chemically react,
so they should have a small value in
electronegativity difference.
If they are both the same size,
they are both crystal structure but
have a high electronegativity
difference, they are going to engage
in electron transfer.
That is no good. But I think this
set of Hume-Rothery Rules is nice to
reflect upon, in light of everything
else we have learned in 3.
91, because the phase diagrams,
as I said earlier, have embedded in
them a lot of basic chemistry which
goes back to electronic structure of
the constituents.
Let's draw a schematic of an AB
diagram for one such system that I
call type one.
I am plotting A versus B.
This is temperature on the vertical
axis. Horizontal axis is
composition. On the left side,
I have pure A. The right side, I
have pure B. And I am looking at
solid-liquid equilibrium.
At this extreme, pure A, this end
member must be the melting
point of pure A.
And the other extreme is pure B.
This is the melting point of pure B.
And I have drawn it just
arbitrarily where the melting point
of B happens to be higher than the
melting point of A,
but it does not matter.
One has to be larger than the other.
This is going to answer the
question how does melting point vary
as a function of composition?
It varies like this. It is not a
straight line for two reasons.
The first one being that when you
take thermodynamics,
subsequently, if you choose to do so,
you will understand the physical
chemistry behind what I am going to
tell you. Let me just state it
without proof that if C is greater
than one, in other words,
if you are not in a pure material,
if you are in a multi-component
system, if C is greater than one,
it is impossible to go from phase 1
to phase 2. You cannot go from
phase 1 to phase 2 without a two
phase region in between.
We cannot go from all liquid to all
solid. Remember,
we said these mix in all proportions
down here. Solids,
you can mix any mix,
any ratio of A and B as solids,
any mix of A and B as liquids. But,
because we must go through a two
phase regime, this opens up to give
a two phase regime. Up here
this is all liquid.
Down here this is all solid.
And in between is a two phase
regime of liquid and solid.
We can call it slush. We have seen
slush before. We have seen ice
slush in water.
The two phase equilibrium for a
pure material.
This is now liquid plus solid in a
multi-component system.
Up here we have single phase liquid
because they are mixing in all
proportions, so this is a solution.
Down here, these are solid solutions.
And in here we have a two phase
regime, a liquid phase homogenous,
a solid phase homogenous. And these
lines are now no longer called the
melting line or the freezing line.
We have two different lines. The
upper line defines the lowest
temperature for any composition.
Pick any composition you want.
This temperature is the lowest
composition at which you have only
liquid present.
Change the composition and that
temperature changes.
But, below this temperature,
you start to see the emergence of
solids. This line here
is called the liquidus.
Liquidus is the line associated with
this reaction.
Single phase liquid goes to liquid
plus solid. And the lower line is
called solidus,
and it represents the complimentary
set.
The solidus is the highest
temperature at any composition for
which you have only solid present.
If you see the line that I have
drawn, the solidus temperature is
the highest temperature for which we
have solid solution present.
If we raise the temperature anymore,
we go in a two phase regime,
some liquid starts to emerge.
The solidus represents the highest
temperature for all solid,
and it represents solid goes to
liquid plus solid,
homogeneous solid.
Let's write it again.
This is the lowest temperature for
only liquid. And this is at any C,
at any value of composition. And a
solidus is the highest temperature
for only solid to be present at any
composition. And this only applies
once you move off of purity.
In here this is showing you how
things vary as a function of
composition. And such a diagram
that has such similarities because
the end members must have common
bonding, common size and so on,
this type of a diagram is called
isomorphous. This is an isomorphous
diagram. And the shape looks like a
lens. It is a lens-shaped diagram.
But if you want to get fancy,
we don't say lens-shaped. We say
lenticular from the Latin.
Lens is lent, degenerative is
lentis, so lenticular.
It is a lenticular diagram.
Now we have it. Let's look at some
example systems that exhibit this
kind of behavior.
Before we do that,
I meant to show you this.
We talked about what happens at
ultra high pressures.
This is water. We are down in here.
This is now kilobars,
thousands of atmospheres.
This is the normal line that you
see. That is this line that I have
shown you. That is here.
There is ice at a density of about
0.92. And normal water is about one,
so ice floats on water.
But, if you keep pressing,
eventually you will force that
crystal structure to change and it
will become more closely packed.
And now you see normal behavior.
Liquid goes to solid. And all of
these different Roman numerals
represent different crystal
structures. Ice has at least nine
different crystal structures,
and some of these are really
interesting. Look at this one.
These are all triple points. This
is ice III, ice I and liquid.
In a single component system,
that is a triple point. That is
uniquely defined.
Now, looks what happens over here.
This is a triple point between ice
VI, ice VII and liquid.
And it is at about 80 degrees C,
way up there. Now look at this one.
This is ice VII. I am in a single
phase regime. It is 100 degrees C.
I have to go to 25 kilobar, but we
have laboratories.
It is 100 degrees C.
And it is not vapor. Remember,
water boils. Normal boiling point
is 100 degrees C.
But, if I apply 25 kilobars,
I go not only through liquid, I go
right across the solid.
You saw I brought the dry ice into
the classroom.
By the way, I was here yesterday
and half of the block was still
sitting there because I left it in
the box and it had this little
comfort zone of CO2 vapor around it.
It was just naturally thinning in.
It took a long time.
What is my point? My point is when
you make such a metastable state and
bring it into some unnatural
conditions, it will last
for a long, long time.
The kinetics are quite slow.
Let's say we go into the lab.
We make ice VII. It is 100 degrees
C, it is 25 kilobar,
and there is a party going on down
the hall. We come out and we have
some ice seven.
It is going to start to want to
melt because the temperature is
going to fall.
You are going to move this way and
down. But some of it is going to be
left. Now you go up to somebody,
you take some ice seven, you drop it
in the drink and the drink heats up
and starts to boil.
And the ice sinks to the bottom of
the glass. That might get someone
to rethink their drinking habits.
This is the power of changing
pressure and temperature.
By the way, those of you who know
"Cat's Cradle" by Kurt Vonnegut,
there is ice IX. It exists. It has
been characterized.
Somebody actually measured this
stuff, and we are still here.
We didn't freeze the whole world,
so you can relax. He needs to
rename that maybe ice 11 or
something. I don't know if there
are any more phases here.
Here is a phase diagram
copper-nickel.
That is a lenticular diagram.
Copper and nickel both FCC metals,
very similar in atomic dimension,
very small electronegativity
difference. You have a lens-shaped
diagram. Copper melts at 1085
centigrade, nickel melts at 1455,
and there is the liquidus and the
solidus.
And in between,
if you cool it at any one of these
concentrations,
you are going to go through this two
phase regime. And we are going to
talk a little bit more about that in
a second. Here is a ceramic system.
Here is nickel oxide, magnesium
oxide. This is an ionic solid.
It is nickel cations, magnesium
cations and oxide anions.
And the nickel and magnesium are
roughly similar in size,
modest electronegativity difference.
And so this one starts at 2000
centigrade, goes up to 2800
centigrade and has a lens-shaped
diagram. Here is one.
This is gold nickel.
It is almost lenticular.
Look at the top part here.
The nickel melting point is up
around 1450. Gold melts at 1063.
It is almost perfectly lenticular
with this little bit of a dip here,
sort of the liquid-solid analogy to
an azeotrope. Again,
you see they are both FCC metals.
But, in this case, the
electronegativity difference is a
little bit larger than you would
like. And so you see a little bit
of a freezing point depression here.
Now I want to go back and talk about
what is going on inside that two
phase regime, because that two phase
regime is peculiar.
Let's see what happens if we take
something of a particular
composition and cool it.
Here is what I am doing.
I am going to blow this up.
And, what I want to do is take
something that is about 40%.
Here is where we are. We are
looking at the liquidus here.
Liquidus line.
And here is the solidus line.
This is all solid. This is single
phase, P equals one,
this is all liquid single phase,
and this is liquid plus solid. And
let's say we drop the temperature
down into the middle of this two
phase regime. What is happening
here, this is a two phase system,
and we have a liquid and a solid.
And the phase diagram tells us the
composition. Here is the sequence.
Let's look at, say, composition C2
there. Composition C2 is about 40%
nickel in copper.
At 1300 degrees C,
we have homogeneous liquid.
And, if we go down to 1200 degrees
C, we have a homogeneous solid.
These are the different grains.
This is liquid, this is solid, and
it is polycrystalline.
And the composition of each of these
grains is the same.
What is happening at 1250?
This diagram says I should have
solid and liquid,
but, look, the composition of that
liquid is not 40% nickel in copper.
The composition is way over here.
It is about 32%.
And the composition of the solid is
up here at about 45%.
This is 32% nickel and this is 45%
nickel. I have a nickel rich solid
and I have a copper rich liquid.
There is a shift. Suppose I take
something of a different
composition.
This is the C2 that is on the
diagram. Here is C1.
I think it starts at around 35%
nickel. This started at 40% nickel.
C1 is 35% nickel. I cool it down
to the same temperature.
It is the same end members.
The liquid at this temperature has
a unique value of nickel content.
It does not matter what the
composition is,
I will always end up with a liquid
of one composition and a solid of
the other composition.
Well, how can I start with two
different? This is 40% and this is
35% nickel. These end members are
the same. There is only one
variable left.
It is the relative amounts of these
because I need conservation of mass.
Because, at the end of the day, if
I add up all of the nickel in the
liquid and all the nickel in the
solid, it still has to
be net 40% nickel.
Only in here it is 45% nickel.
Up here it is 32% nickel. I have a
Vernier scale.
I have a sliding scale that I can
move so that if I have something
that is 35%, in other words,
it needs less of this phase, so the
35% is going to end up doing this.
Whereas, the 40% is going to end up
doing this. It is the relative
amounts. This line that tells me
what the concentration of the solid
and the liquid at any temperature is
called the "tie line."
The tie line defines the composition
end members, the liquid and the
solid in that two phase regime.
And we can take all of this that I
have been talking about and we can
codify it in terms of a simple rule
that captures the notion of phase
separation and conservation of mass.
And that is called the "lever rule."
The lever rule answers the question,
how much of each phase is present?
The relative amount present of each
phase in the two phase region.
For example, here we are with the
40% nickel. It is 40% nickel in
copper. We have dropped down into
the two phase regime,
draw the tie line. And the tie line
tells us that the liquid will
proportionate as follows.
This is 40% nickel at all liquid.
Now we drop the temperature. This
is 1300. Now we drop down to 1250.
And we know, according to the phase
diagram, we are going to end up with
a liquid and a solid.
And, furthermore,
the tie line tells us that the solid
is going to be 45% nickel and the
liquid is going to be 32% nickel.
The question is what are the
relative values?
It is shown right up there on the
transparency that the percent of the
liquid is equal to,
in this case, the end member 45
minus the individual amount at the
concentration of the bulk divided by
the end members of the tie line.
And we will multiply that by 100%.
And that gives us a value of 38%
present as liquid.
And why is it called the lever rule?
Because, if you look at the tie
line, here is where we are.
We are at this value which is shown
in the phase diagram as z.
This is our 40%. And the amount of
the liquid is x and the amount
of the solid is y.
And so, when I am asking how much
liquid is present,
I choose the amount opposite,
as you do on a seesaw or
teeter-totter.
In other words,
to calculate what the force is here,
you take the amount between the
fulcrum and the opposite side
divided by the total length.
This is yz over xy. It gives us
liquid. And then the compliment
gives us the amount for solid.
You see that worked out for you on
the transparency.
And this works for any two phase
regime. Whenever something drops
into a two phase regime,
disproportionation has to occur,
and the lever rule will give you the
relative amounts.
The tie line tells you the
composition and the lever rule tells
you the relative amounts.
Two things. I want this to be like
you are that Manchurian candidate.
This is your cue.
From now on, if you hear two phase,
you just go lever rule. What are
the end members?
Tie line, lever rule whenever you
see two phase regime.
And it will keep you out of trouble.
I mean, many times I get into
trouble. I just think of the lever
rule and I am out of trouble.
Now let's look at a second case.
Second case is type two phase
diagram in contrast to
complete solubility.
Type two phase diagram is
characterized by a system that has
partial or limited solubility.
When you try to mix A and B, they
do not mix in all proportions.
They only mix up to a certain point.
That is like a solubility limit or
a miscibility.
Miscibility and solubility are
synonymous.
This leads to a miscibility gap.
A range of composition over which
you cannot mix the two of them and
form a homogeneous solution.
And, in this case, there is no
change of state.
That is either always liquid or
always solid. Let's look at the
phase diagram for one of
these type of systems.
A. B. I am plotting composition
across the abscissa.
The ordinate is temperature.
And this gives us a synclinal phase
diagram. Above we have single phase.
This is single phase and
this is dual phase.
For example, this could be all
liquid. And then in here we have
two liquids. Or,
it could be all solid.
And inside here we have two solids.
When it comes to solid solutions
people use Greek letters and call
this alpha and beta.
This is the coexistence curve or
the solubility limit.
What is the coexistence curve?
The coexistence curve is liquid is
in equilibrium with liquid one and
liquid two. In other words,
if you drop into this two phase
regime, what happens as soon as you
hear two phase?
Tie line, lever rule.
The tie line will give you the
concentrations at the end,
or solid goes to alpha plus beta.
Both of these are solid solutions.
Let's take a look at some of these.
This is gold nickel. At low
temperatures look what happens.
Gold nickel will actually phase
separate. If you take something
like this one here,
which is 50 weight percent nickel,
at high temperatures they mix in all
proportions. Drop into here,
we have a slush consisting of liquid
and solid. And they have different
compositions given by the tie line.
Drop even lower in temperature and
all of a sudden it is a single phase
solid solution,
FCC lattice with gold and nickel
atoms 50/50. Well,
in this case it is weight percent so
it is not exactly on an atomic basis.
There it is about 75.
And then we drop into lower
temperatures, and now they phase
separate. We end up,
for example, at 600 degrees.
Let's get down to, say, room
temperature. This is 300 degrees C,
but the lines are starting to get
fairly steep.
What you find is that it will phase
separate so that you will end up
with zones that are nickel rich and
zones that are gold rich.
And the tie line tells you the
compositions of both of those end
members. Here is one,
hexane-nitrobenzene. At high
temperatures they mix in all
proportions. You drop the
temperature and then they phase
separate, just as oil and water.
Down at this temperature, you will
have a hexane rich phase and a
nitrobenzene rich phase.
And, the lower and lower you get in
temperature, the greater that
separation. Think about it at this
constant temperature.
What this is saying is that you can
put a certain amount of nitrobenzene
into hexane, and that is the
solubility limit.
If you try to put any more
nitrobenzene into hexane,
it won't go in. On the other side,
it says you can put a small amount
of hexane in nitrobenzene.
If you try to put any more,
it won't go in. It will just
precipitate out.
This makes sense to you,
doesn't it?
Furthermore, at this temperature,
I can put, say, 0.1 units of
nitrobenzene. If I raise the
temperature, the solubility goes up
with temperature.
All of this is making sense.
Finally, you get to a temperature
here above which they mix in all
proportions. This temperature is
called the "consolute" temperature.
Above the consolute temperature,
even a system that has a propensity
for limited solubility will mix in
all proportions.
You see this in different systems.
This one is a surprise.
This is two alkali halides,
sodium chloride and potassium
chloride. You would expect those to
just trade off with one another,
but there is a problem here. The
sodium ion and the potassium ion are
different enough in atomic dimension,
different enough in charge density
that, as you get to low temperatures,
they phase separate.
Instead of making a perfect solid
solution at lower temperatures,
the single phase solid solution
breaks into a potassium rich solid
solution and a sodium
rich solid solution.
Here is from the polymer world.
This one is polystyrene,
polybutadiene.
At high temperatures,
you can mix them and make a
copolymer, a copolymer mix in all
proportions. As you drop the
temperature, they will phase
separate. And you will end up with
something that has islands of a
polystyrene rich phase.
Not pure polystyrene. There is a
certain amount of polybutadiene in
it. And then the other phase will
be polybutadiene with a certain
amount of polystyrene.
They phase separate.
Here is one. Certain systems,
instead of exhibiting a consolute
temperature in this fashion,
for entropic reasons the system is
flipped upside down.
This is a lower critical
temperature. This is weird because
normally you think as you raise
temperature you increase solubility.
This is one case where it goes the
inverse. Water triethylamine mixes
in all proportions at low
temperature. At higher temperatures
there is the --
Instead of being synclinal,
this is anticlinal. It is a U
shaped curve. Single phase out here.
Down here they mix in all
proportions. Up here you can put a
certain amount of triethylamine in
and then it stops.
Then you get the second phase.
Here is the weirdest one of all.
This is nicotine and water. It has
an upper critical point and a lower
critical point.
At low temperatures,
you can mix nicotine and water in
all proportions.
And, at very high temperatures,
you can mix nicotine and water in
all proportions.
And at intermediate temperatures
they phase separate.
There is the map that tells you how
the system behaves as a function of
temperature and composition.
In here you cannot get a
homogeneous solution.
If you try to make a 50/50 mix of
water and nicotine and you heat that
to 100 degrees C,
it will phase separate.
Even though you will mix it at room
temperature, and it will be
homogeneous, as you raise the
temperature all of a sudden you will
see milkiness, globs of one
forming in the other.
What would happen if we were to take
60% sodium chloride and cool it down
to, say, 400 degrees C?
What happens? Bingo. Tie line.
P equals two, so the homogenous
solid solution breaks into an alpha,
which is the designation for the
potassium chloride rich solid
solution, and beta,
which is the designation for the
sodium chloride rich solid solution.
And how do we figure out the
relative amounts of alpha and beta?
Lever rule. It is a two phase
regime. Lever rule.
That is it. Now I will do a little
experiment here to show you how this
works. I want to work with a simple
system. This is ouzo and water.
Ouzo is a drink, a liqueur from the
absinthe family.
And wormwood is the chief flavoring
agent. It contains licorice,
hyssop, fennel, angelica root,
aniseed. The thing is it has a lot
of oil in it. It is very oily.
It is clear and colorless but very
oily. And then water,
of course. You know what water is.
Let's have a look.
Can we cut to the document camera
here? What I am going to do is --
Here is water and here is ouzo.
These are at room temperature. I
am assuming the phase diagram looks
like this. I can put a little bit
of ouzo into water,
and I can put a little bit of water
into ouzo, but if I exceed these
solubility limits,
in here this is milky because it is
two phase.
This is milky and this is clear.
Why? Because this is single phase
and this is P equals two.
We are going to do an experiment
here. What I am going to do is put,
this is just pure water, and you
know what pure water looks like,
distilled water. And here is some
ouzo. And this is clear
and colorless as well.
Now what I am going to do is pour
water into the ouzo.
If I pour a little bit in,
I can stir this, and it will
dissolve. What I am doing here is
pouring water into ouzo and I am
coming across.
If I pour too much water in,
I am going to hit this miscibility
gap, and this will precipitate out.
And when it precipitates out, it
has a different index, it
is going to look milky.
In fact, I think I have already hit
there. Look at this.
I have crossed the miscibility gap.
Now, if my hunch is correct, I
should be able to keep adding water
and eventually emerge on this side.
Let's see what happens.
We will dilute it.
I am going to pour this down to
almost a tiny fraction.
And I will pour in more.
I have crossed the miscibility gap.
I can do it the other way. Let's
start with water.
We can go across or we can do the
other. It doesn't matter.
Now, what is the difference between
this and absinthe?
Absinthe is similar,
but it has a little more color to it.
Absinthe is green.
And so, when you add water to
absinthe, you are supposed to add it
five parts water and one part
absinthe. We are going to make the
louche which is the milky.
This is the way absinthe would be
drunk. You can see how milky this
is. Now, when Toulouse-Lautrec
drank, he made a drink called the
"Earthquake." What he did with the
earthquake is he added cognac to the
absinthe louche.
What are we going to do here?
What is the chemistry? The
chemistry is the following.
I have oil droplets here in water.
Oil.
And then over here is water.
What I am going to do is put ethyl
alcohol, CH3CH2OH.
And what does the OH do?
The OH makes a hydrogen bond.
I have a hydrophilic head. Ethyl
alcohol is amphipathic.
And this is a hydrophobic tail.
The hydrophobic tail can stab the
oily phase of the louche.
This is what you do in cooking.
How many recipes will ask you to
add a little bit of alcohol?
And they will subsequently ask you
to heat it. And you say,
well, wait a minute, alcohol is
going to evaporate.
What is going on? Whenever they
are asking for alcohol,
chances are you are adding something
fatty to an aqueous solution and it
does not want to mix.
As soon as you add the alcohol it
cosolvates.
Alcohol is magical for this
amphipathic character.
Let's make the Earthquake.
The Earthquake is like this.
We are going to add a little bit of
this. It is a beautiful green-gold
color, but it is clear because what
has happened now,
I have put in a third component.
Now I have got water, ouzo, alcohol.
And as I add alcohol,
I narrow the miscibility gap.
The miscibility gap narrows as a
result of that.
It is fantastic.
May we go back to the computer
graphic, please?
This is where we were.
We were along this tie line.
And I figured the louche is here.
It is five parts water, one part
absinthe. And then away we go.
This is the late 1800s. Why did
absinthe take over in France?
Because there was a blight that
wiped out the vineyards.
And so the price of wine shot up and
people started turning to absinthe.
You hear he is making the louche.
He is pouring water through a
slotted spoon on which there is a
sugar cube. And here is a woman
looking at him saying,
wow, is he ever cool, what a guy.
Hey, it's the 1800s. This is an
object of art.
This is Van Gogh.
This is Picasso. This is the
absinthe drinker.
This is Picasso after he,
I guess, had a lot of absinthe.
The only thing I can recognize here
is the slotted spoon with what
appears to be a rather large sugar
cube. And this is somebody's mind
after huge quantities of it.
The thing about it is it had
thujone in it,
which comes from the white cedar.
And what this does is it
antagonized the receptors that
regulate neuron firing.
We can think much faster,
but we kind of slow ourselves down.
It is the gamma-aminobutyric acid
that helps us stay in place.
Actually, epileptics suffer from a
lack of regulation.
And that is a motor regulation,
but in the case of mental acuity.
This is one of these cases where
the alcohol tracks with the thujone.
And so instead of making you drunk
and stupid, it makes you drunk and
very, very highly active.
But unfortunately large quantities
of it also had other neurological
disorders. If you have seen Moulin
Rouge, you will see here,
it is all about absinthe in that
period.
What happened was this absinthe took
over. I mean,
people drank huge quantities of this
in place of wine.
Eventually, the wine was restored.
The vineyards in France were
restored by grafting onto American
stocks. There are very few wines in
France that are not produced as
hybrids on American stock.
Occasionally, you will see a bottle
of wine that says vieux vin,
old vine, meaning that it was spared
from the Phylloxera blight.
By and large, it is not American
vine. French wines are grown on
American roots,
just remember that.
Now the wine cooperatives wanted to
get people to switch back to wine,
so there was this strange alliance
between the wine cooperatives and
the temperance movement to get
people to stop drinking absinthe.
And so what happened was there were
a number of murder trials in which
somehow it was portrayed that
absinthe figured prominently.
And so, little by little governments
banned it. This is October 7,
1910 where absinthe is being banned
in Switzerland.
Here it says, Gentlemen,
this is the hour. And this is the
symbol of absinthe.
Absinthe was known affectionately
as the "green fairy."
That is why in Moulin Rouge you
will see this sort of Tinkerbell
type figure, Nicole Kidman playing
this Tinkerbell figure in an
animation. Well, she
is the green fairy.
And she has a wand made of opal
because the beverage is opalescent.
When it shimmers, you have
gradients in index of refraction to
give you that internal incipient
surface. Here is the green fairy
slain by the temperance movement and
so on. The last thing I wanted to
comment on is how we use the two
phase regime in purification.
Much of what we know about
purification requires that we go
into a two-phase regime.
Because the thing that happens in a
two phase regime is two phase region
implies compositional
differentiation.
For example, here is the phase
diagram. For one time,
I am going to go to liquid vapor.
This is the liquid vapor phase
diagram of ethyl alcohol and water.
We know that water boils at 100
degrees C. This is normal boiling
point. And ethyl alcohol boils at
78.5 degrees C.
And they are both polar liquids.
Ethyl alcohol is a little bit more
elongated than water.
It is very nearly an isomorphous
phase diagram.
There is a tiny little dip but,
by and large, it is an isomorphous
phase diagram.
Alcohol and water,
miscible in all proportions in the
vapor, obviously.
And this is the liquid.
This is the two phase liquid plus
vapor regime. Let's say you have
some wine and it is 10% alcohol.
What do you do? You heat the wine
up to this two phase regime.
And now, in the two phase regime,
tie line. What do you note? You
note that the alcohol content of the
vapor is much higher than the
alcohol content of the liquid.
What we can do is condense the
vapor, which puts us down here,
and now reheat. Condense. Reheat.
Condense.
And, by doing so,
we can raise the alcohol content.
Or, in some cases, this could be
the way you purify for the liquid.
It doesn't matter. You either want
the condensate or you want what was
the base from which you took the
condensate. And this is used over
and over again.
It is used in the solid-state to
purify metals.
Look up here on the slide.
Suppose I have a solution that
consists of, over here
of, say, 60% nickel.
It is all liquid.
Drop it down into this two phase
regime. The solid that comes out
has very much less gold in it.
That means that the liquid behind,
the last liquid to solidify is going
to have more gold in it than the
bulk that I started with.
I can keep taking that fraction by
moving into a regime where the
composition splits.
And I either want the high fraction
or the low fraction.
This is the principle by which,
in fact, the computer-grade silicon
is made. We start with beach sand.
We upgrade to something that has to
be about four or five nines silicon
for single crystal growth.
How do we go from something that is
about 98% silicon,
2% impurities to such a high degree
of purification?
By dropping repeatedly into the two
phase regime and pulling
out the pure fraction.
The key here is compositional
differentiation,
which then allows you to distill.
You start with 10%, you end up 40%,
you go from wine and end up with
brandy or cognac.
There it is. It is all back to
chemistry, chemistry,
chemistry. OK. We will see you on
Wednesday.